So we covered a lot of material in the customer segment part of the business model canvas.
We talked about the jobs to be done. We talked about pains. We talked about gains.
We talked about multi-sided markets, and we've closed with market type.
Let me give you an example of a couple of startups who actually went
and tried to define our customer segments.
So here was one.
The startup was actually trying to understand how to find foreign students at universities,
and so they were putting together their archetype and this was just the definition of meet the student
and here's who they are and here's their family and oh this is their first time in America.
And because it was about providing financial services to foreign students,
they actually understood something about their credit score, about social security number,
US address, whether they were responsible academically and financially,
and whether their social network was responsible.
Another example of a customer segment was someone making new kite boarding equipment.
Who were their customers? Professional kite surfers.
They're solely concerned with performance. But they had another segment. Average kite surfers.
And they had a third, prospective kite surfers, and though I don't think they were this young
they were actually trying to understand how to segment their market
and what their specific performance needs for kite surfs were in each segment.
The other thing that we're interested in doing if you remember in customer segments is
understanding a day in the life of a customer.
Now sometimes this could actually be diagrammed as to how do they spend their time.
And this happens to be how does a designer spend their time
putting together an architectural product.
So how much they spend in phase 1 and then in prototyping and manufacturing and final product,
and so this was giving them a view of what it would look like and so they can now describe to me
and others, "Oh! And our product fits right here and here's why," etc.
Here was another example of someone trying to understand the customer problem
of couples who happen to be on separate coasts or long distance from each other.
And they were trying to understand what the problems were and so they were able to
articulate all the key pieces and kind of rank them by priority.
And I thought that this was a great way to kind of diagram the problem.
Here was another example of a team putting together a detailed archetype
of a set of customers.
They gave their archetype a name, Pat the Professional.
Specified who Pat was, upwardly mobile professional, salaries, what they did,
how much they spend, what their demographics are, what their traits were,
what their motivations were, how many were there, where they worked, where they bought, etc.
I thought this was a great example of a professional class consumer
who was shopping frequently online.
Another example, in medical devices, trying to understand two segments,
oncologists and pathologists, here's what they did, here's what they cared about,
and more importantly here's how they're paid.
Here's how they're paid in the hospital and here's how they got reimbursed.
Here's another example of a mammography product,
how patient care works inside of a hospital and how people got reimbursed.
So you could find these examples and more on the link below.